guys uh can I say something Ernie oh I
think you already are okay uh this is
big this is big I want to be the first
I'm the only person up here knows this I
want to be the first person that's an
honor and a privilege to congratulate
Ernie Johnson going into the sports
broadcasting Hall of Fame
get out of here yeah
uh they they told me and I said they
said would you do this I said be an
honored it's an honor and a privilege to
tell you
Ernie Johnson congratulations brother
yeah man that is that is awesome thank
you so much I and you know what I'm
taking the rest of the day off
thank you guys and whoever whoever is
responsible for that whoever votes on
that I am humbled beyond words so thank
you so much means the world to me I've
been in this been at this for uh been at
this for 34 years at the same place been
over 40 years in broadcasting and uh
I'm stunned so thank you so much I
appreciate that very much
um thank you guys hey Underdog what a
cool day huh thanks man uh well we're
going to take a break in just a second
and uh and start the match and don't you
ever do that again to me
trying to hold it together all the
famous that's it